an executive at Amazon is really pushing
for a Stargate movie a movie that nobody
else wants but why is this such a
problem and why is it causing such
delays welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi
TV and movie channel
[Music]
so we have been following this story for
God nearly two years now waiting for MGM
to get off its backside and make a
Stargate series to make a new franchise
but we are still waiting there have been
lots of delays for one MGM was sold
Amazon bought it then MGM was a complete
mess and Amazon wanted to restructure
everything that restructure is actually
still not complete and now we're waiting
because Amazon can't actually decide
what to do with the franchise does it
want to do a movie a television series
or both or neither it really can't make
its mind up and I have to say at this
point the incompetence of the people at
Amazon and MGM is really starting to
become frustrated they really do need to
just put their heads together decide
what they want to do and do it but they
can't seem to now I'm going to tell you
exactly which executive it is at the
moment at Amazon that is putting a gun
in the works but before I do I just
think it's fair to tell you that at MGM
they've been pushing to do a television
series according to my sources they've
never wanted to do a Stargate movie
Michael Wright is the head of scripted
material at MGM he believes and has
always firmly believed the Stargate
would make a fine addition to MGM plus
and potentially Amazon Prime um
elsewhere in the world and that a
television series is the way to go he's
never believed apparently that Stargate
would be successful enough as a movie to
kick-start a franchise and apparently
his feelings have never changed Mark
Fergus owned part of penguin in a Parker
the guys that did the expanses come in
and he apparently agrees with Michael
Wright he has said again the whole way
that this franchise needs to be a
television series and then potentially
straight to Prime movies and at a later
date he argued and to be honest I
probably agree with him that this
franchise just isn't big enough to
support a big movie and to be honest all
the franchises are moving away from
Cinema releases
this is even true for other franchises
you can argue are bigger Jonathan Frakes
very recently said the future of Star
Trek is television he probably he
doesn't actually foresee a return to
cinema now I can completely understand
why because cinema at the moment it's
like the wild west it can go either way
big movies like Avatar whatever can
still make billions of dollars but other
films just lose money hand over fist and
end up on streaming services anyway
streaming platforms like Netflix and
Amazon Prime and everybody else are
making virtually Cinema quality movies
but putting them straight onto their
streaming platforms and that seems to be
the trend moving forwards there is
significantly less risk of doing it that
way
so why is Amazon pushing for a cinematic
release if there is a big risk and and I
will repeat again there is a huge risk
to the franchise if they do decide to go
the cinema release and that risk
basically is what if it doesn't actually
do very well now from the perspective of
a fan I want a TV series I think there
is a much lower risk I think it would be
pretty much guaranteed to be successful
however a cinematic release well Gators
will be very excited about it but is
there going to really be a big audience
for a movie that would actually appease
Gators now we've talked about this a lot
on our previous lives and really to
appease Gators it needs to be a
continuation of the story but to appease
a wider audience they can't rely too
much on what happened in the series
because those people didn't watch it so
it would have to be some sort of
Standalone series now if they did do a
cinematic release and it wasn't
successful because Gators weren't happy
in a wider audience didn't get found
then the film would lose money and we
would have absolutely no chance of
getting a TV series to follow that is
the biggest risk of a cinematic release
but Amazon are pushing for that and the
executive that is the problem is named
Jennifer salkey now Jennifer sulky has
been involved in a couple of the
meetings between penguin and Parker MGM
and Amazon in the past she has been
involved in this all the way
and why is she pushing for cinematic
release because she is the head of
Amazon Studios if there was to be a
cinematic release she'd be in charge it
would come from her department so this
way she can actually get involved also
Amazon do want to make eight or nine
cinematic movies a year and have put in
aside a big money billions of dollars to
do so this is a massive project for her
and Jennifer sulky is desperate for
material to actually produce she sees
Stargate as an easy win but no one else
agrees apparently as I said Michael
Wright and Mark Fergus have been arguing
against Jennifer sulky from the
beginning and they continue to do so
this really might end up having to go
above Jennifer sulky to the other
Executives to make a decision but they
need to make a decision because again my
sources are telling me that Mark Fergus
is starting to get a little frustrated
by the whole situation he wants to begin
development and to do that he really
needs to know what format the story is
going to be told him if he has to do a
cinematic release followed by a series
or a series that would lead up to maybe
a straight to Prime video movie or
something like that he really needs to
know because it really affects the way
the story will be developed he really
can't start until they at least tell him
where to start so once again we're
waiting on Amazon to make a bloody
decision and they need to get their
thumbs out of their backsides and make
that decision because to be honest this
isn't a complicated one this isn't like
Mark fergus's job where he has to come
up with a completely new story and you
know he has to do all that creative
stuff all they need to decide is the
business side of it
they have loads of metadata about how
popular potentially Stargate would be
they have people Bean counters basically
that do all these algorithms and a bit
of math and project how well projects
will do
apparently they've done all of this work
already and actually MGM did it again
over two years ago they know what the
chances of success are now I'm not going
to pretend that I do and I'm not going
to pretend that I've seen those numbers
because I haven't
but
they do and if people like Michael
Wright headed scripted material at MGM
doesn't think a cinematic release is a
good idea then I would suggest that
those numbers aren't as strong as
Jennifer sulky thinks
so if that is the case then a TV series
is surely the way to go
and we know in the past that Amazon and
MGM have both spoken about how the TV
audience for this project is the
audience that matters Roland emmerich
confirm that for us
so again a TV series is surely the way
to go Jennifer sulky needs to really get
the hell out of the way and start
letting other people make decisions
because this constant delay is really
just putting the entire project in more
and more Jeopardy and I have to say I
continue to hear Whispers that this
franchise might not happen at all if it
doesn't happen soon this whole thing
about we need to know sort of by April
is a serious deadline and a proper
deadline if we haven't heard by then
then I'm afraid we might not be hearing
anything at all
so guys get into the comments tell me
what you think do you want Jennifer
salkey to get the hell out of the way
and just let them make a TV show or do
you actually think she's right would a
cinematic release of Stargate actually
be worthwhile would it actually be the
great way to kick start the franchise or
is she just a bloody idiot and she
really needs to get over herself and let
other people crack on
I'd love to know exactly what you think
please give him the comments if you are
new to the Channel please like subscribe
hit that Bell notification really helps
us out and if you want to really support
the channel consider hitting the join
button there's also load of links in the
description for our Discord server our
merchandise page our Facebook page and
nine Chevrons the website that is
dedicated completely to Stargate news
please get in there and have a look as
always please stay safe and I'll see you
next time
foreign
[Music]